[Musique]
après cette mort on sent ce soir qu'une
polémique vive dur est prête à s'engager
le directeur de minute justifier
l'attitude de son journal celui du
canard enchaîné se défend d'avoir
calomnié au passage il attaque les
moyens officiels et officieux comme il
dit d'information parce qu'ils ont fait
un rapprochement certains d'entre eux du
moins un rapprochement avec l' affaire
salengro
vous savez le ministre du front
populaire qui s'était suicidé en 1937
par une campagne de presse féroce le
faisaient apparaître comme traître
lors de la guerre pour notre part à vous
qui nous regarde et nous vous laisserons
soigneusement la dure et seraient une
réflexion malgré le drame qui conduira
serait une réflexion sur ce drame qui
conduira à votre propre jugement
pardon nous ferrons juste observer au
passage sans nous mêler de ce qu'ont dit
nos confrères sont jugés leur liberté ça
les regarde que le moment n'est pas venu
de mettre tout le monde dans le même
panier des censeurs comme l'a dit le
canard ce soir puisque les journalistes
de télévision peut être droit eux aussi
à leur part de respectabilité
ces deux batailles là ne sera en tout
cas pas celle de cette rédaction pour
refermer cette édition spéciale pensant
à autre chose de plus constructif
laissons parler un homme qui a bien de
la sagesse ce soir bien de la tolérance
aussi me semble-t-il le fils bertrand
belin un homme de coeur qui passe sa vie
depuis dix ans au service des enfants et
qui me semble faire preuve dans sa
douleur et son chagrin d'une très belle
élévation d'esprit dans ton dos un
immense honnêteté on est mise en cause
ça l'a bouleversée pourtant c'est un
homme qui a donné l'image d'un insolite
nerfs d'acier sagesse qui ne ressemble
pas à vous faire une confidence
on a beau être lorsque l'on vient sur un
certain nombre de terrains et veulent
c'est pas vrai c'est mouiller d'attac
malgré votre solidité et je dirais à
cause de votre solidité car l'équilibré
fragile à cause de cette solidité je
crois qu'on est frais je crois que comme
les chênes qu'on abat
un coup laisse pas dans un chêne il peut
s'abattre file d'un camp même si ce vent
est mauvais et je crois que c'est ce qui
lui est arrivé et c'est une tragédie
pour nous tous on nous sommes
bouleversés nous sommes terrifiés me
direz qu'on est inquiet aussi parce que
chez nous on n'a pas des hommes comme
lui ça me paraît très gras elle revient
aujourd'hui en l'avenir on cherchera des
responsabilités mais ce que je veux dit
en tant que fils et il faut le prendre
comme tel c'est que il était d'abord
c'est un homme je me sens vous faire de
confidences qui depuis douze ans dans
mes buts pour les enfants maïté
entièrement affectivement amicalement
c'est une perte immense pour mu manque
et c'est une tragédie mais je suis
inquiet parce que je ne saisis pas bien
ce qui a pu la battre
or ces attaques
[Musique]